all right let's go through a couple
things i've been saving up this week and
just didn't really have time for until
today as many of you know we've been
following the supposed bankruptcy of uh
infowars conspiracy theorist alex jones
where he says they don't really have any
money but then they got two one million
dollar bitcoin donations and now they've
got five million but they still don't
have enough money to pay any of the
sandy hook parents in the settlement
that they filed and won against alex
jones for defamation it's all a complete
and total mess alex jones seemed to
almost have like a medical event
almost like stroking out or having a
cardiac event during his show
where he seemed to be saying
they are in a war they i don't know if
these infowars or the american right
wing or who they are in a war and the
only way to win the war
is for you to buy his products including
his supplements and to send him money
this is really full-on stuff it's
simultaneously hilarious
but also extraordinarily weird and
supporting our guests because everybody
we have on is fighting with everything
they've got whoa this is a war against
you and your family of inflation and
collapse it's really like a try decaf
type of moment here
and they know everybody's going to wake
up in the midst of that's why they want
to silence the leaders because they
think they can then defeat you so when
you keep us in the fight you keep
yourself in the fight and this is life
and death right so go to
and get amazing products and sign up for
autoship and continue support make a
donation at the top and go to the stone
defense fund and make a nation to him
because he's a gladiator and a champion
and now they have supplements up on the
screen energy supplements and stuff like
that fight and if you don't support us
you're helping the enemy and i'm not
bitching at lester's i'm telling you
this is all about war roger
well alex i think you're absolutely
right about yeah alex jones uh agrees
with that globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shun like obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
that's my alex jones impression from uh
from from last year
this is absolutely hilarious but also we
really need to make sure that everybody
following the bankruptcy proceedings is
aware of what's going on here you know
this whole like we will only win this
moral war
if you buy my supplements and contribute
to my personal finances
which i claim i don't even have because
i said i'm bankrupt
it it's it it's beyond parody at this
point in time and there is you know even
though alex jones alex jones does kowtow
to religion to some degree but it's not
as overtly a religious show as some
others the supplement stuff it's
starting to remind me of those
evangelical tv shows that sell the food
storage the mad the buckets of food
this is jim baker
offering buckets and it's basically like
a less manic alex jones this is the most
unique
survival food
this is 52 servings right turkey feast
emergency food supply that's right and
this food is 30 years shelf life food it
is even has pump by the way one of the
things i love is that he says it has a
30-year shelf life but at the bottom of
the screen it says it has a 20-year
shelf life it's like wait so does it
last 20 years or 30 years pumpkin pie
mousse for dessert it doesn't mean we
made it the other day it's super
delicious actually i love pumpkin pie
pumpkin pie moose i've never even heard
of that it has honey wheat rolls green
bean casserole like a lot of you make
i have to tell you the green bean
casserole and the pumpkin pie mousse
look basically the same turkey gravy
seasoned stuffing
freeze-dried turkey
the freeze-dried turkey does look like
dog food mashed potatoes
this
for your survival food
this is to have isn't that the best the
apocalypse is coming we are about to be
raptured but you'll be able to enjoy a
completely typical thanksgiving dinner
thanks to my turkey feast survival food
bucket it's the same thing as with the
alex jones segment right it's we're in a
war here and they're trying to silence
you and they're trying to silence me and
the way to fight it
is by buying supplements on my website
it's like a stupidity test i saw a
cartoon with a vending machine
and the vending machine said if you
think the election was rigged insert 100
and it's sort of the same stupidity if
you think alex jones it it's a stupidity
test if you think buying alex jones
supplements will save america
then just send him money and if you pass
the test you get to keep your money it's
really a tragedy of education that
people fall for this stuff in the united
states to the tune of millions of
dollars and as far as the bankruptcy
proceedings with alex jones hopefully
they're paying attention to everything
that's happening with this business i
want to do a short segment on uh don jr
and maria bartoromo maria bartiromo has
become one of the biggest trump family
brown nosers uh really in the world but
in particular on fox news and she had a
wild interview and i i'm not making any
speculative claims about don jr's
possible upper use i'm just not going to
do that on this show i'm just going when
i say he seems sped up i just mean it
seems like the videos of him talking are
sped up and donald trump jr has now
co-founded something called mxm news i
have no idea what it is it it's very
uninteresting to me but it's like
they've got rumble they've got truth
social now it's mxm news who can even
keep track of all these different things
uh and he showed up
and um
he is talking about
a panic about free speech and different
things these interviews just go nowhere
to conservatives for a decade now like
these people are living in a bubble
they're not looking for a level playing
field maria they're looking for an
advantage they were always thrilled when
they have that advantage as though they
don't have enough advantages already
right they control the mainstream media
a trillion dollar enterprise they have
basically i love when they go on fox and
slam the mainstream media as if fox news
isn't part of the same corporate media
apparatus that they criticize all of big
tech another trillion dollar enterprise
they had all of social media again until
you came up with truth social and then
elon musk said hey how about some free
speech on twitter as well oh my god you
know the outrage and the panic and you
see it and that's why you see the leak
about the supreme court they need
something and they have nothing to
motivate their people now remember it
increa we still don't know who did the
supreme court leak but it's increasingly
looking like the best hypotheses are
that it was a right winger who did the
leak but that's just not convenient for
them american people are awake to it uh
they're starting to see what's real wow
they're awake it almost sounds like
they're woke what happened to the
algorithms the second the musk thing was
announced they saw the engagement that
they're getting on social and they
realized that they've been in a rigged
game for very long they see it and you
can no longer hide it maria and now the
crazy thing about this appearance other
than the fact that everything that he
says doesn't make any sense is he was so
hopped up on let's call it uh energy
that
he ranted for several minutes to the
point where maria bartoromo tried to
interrupt him and was isn't even able to
disinformation until it wasn't uh once
they got what they wanted the truth no
longer mattered so now they can say it's
true they see the disaster that joe's uh
biden's administration is so now they're
saying hey we'll throw him under the bus
let's let this be true now so check out
mxm news because those stories existed
but the powers that be made sure that
people never actually saw them and so we
have to make sure that people have
access to this kind of information and
so whether it's truth social whether
it's mxm news we are pushing back and
people are finally awake she has no
ability to actually take control of the
interview and this mxm news thing if you
check it out it's it says
mainstream news
without the mainstream bias
and it's available i guess it's an app
of some kind
that lets you cut through the noise
and
it's curated with no with no censorship
now i don't know how many people
understand that but
it's very hard to say something is
curated with no censorship i mean the
criticism that they have of the facebook
and twitter and etc algorithms are
it's being curated in a way we don't
like
they will often say
if twitter and facebook weren't censored
they would just be
chronological messages from everybody
you follow
the
algorithm that curates is a form of
censorship and they're promoting mxm
news as being
curated
but without any censorship it makes as
little sense as it sounds like it makes
monday memorial day we will be doing our
a midterm membership bonanza we will be
blowing out memberships at a massive
discount everybody on my team is saying
david sir
please don't do it
don't do it it's too much of a discount
and i am telling them i'm doing it on
memorial day you'll all be sleeping and
i'll be giving out discounted
memberships if you want to be notified
of this great discount and you want to
sign up on monday memorial day just get
on our newsletter at davidpakman.com
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is of course a
community supported program you can sign
up at joinpackman.com
and instantly get access to the world
winning i'm sorry
award-winning
and world-famous bonus show
you can sign up at joinpackman.com
and you can use the coupon code obama
for a discount
very important stuff at joinpakman.com
let's speak to some people
in the audience right i mean i think
that that makes absolute and perfect
sense
you can join the discussion on our
discord at davidpakman.com
discord we use the waiting lobby
to indicate that you would like to speak
to me and of course do not send me any
direct messages we have a system get in
the waiting lobby if you send me direct
messages saying david david please put
me on unfortunately i have to mute you
and i will never hear from you again
that's the way it works
let's go
first
to our friend jen in providence jen
great to have you back on
uh hi can you hear me i can hear you
fine
all right great um so you know living in
a liberal area like new england a lot of
people have that peace of mind thinking
oh as far as the abortion rights they're
never going to come for us we're going
to be safe up here
but do you think it really is
only a matter of time until they just
really try to make it federal and try to
creep up i mean rhode island is even
almost purple it's not solid blue like
massachusetts is right do you think
we're in any danger in the future
i think it would be a bad idea to assume
that they're never coming for abortion
with a federal abortion ban in fact
there's already people talking about it
there's already people saying hey listen
if we can get rid of roe v wade maybe a
total ban would actually be a
possibility so i think to your point jen
it would be
at one's own peril to put our guard down
and to say well as long as we just lobby
for it to remain legal within the states
in which we live we don't have to worry
about it that seems extremely dangerous
and naive to me now i'm not saying
they will get a federal abortion ban
necessarily anytime soon but they we
don't have to wonder whether they're
thinking about it they're telling us
that they're thinking about it
yeah what's interesting about the design
of providence too we get to see the
effects of if they did go through with
this ban on one street there is a
planned parenthood a homeless shelter
and department of human services so it's
kind of showing that triad of what
happens if these women are meant to have
kids that they can't afford yeah
um but none of these people who are
screaming pro-life are going to you know
the homeless shelter and donating and
they're the same ones they get mad when
they have to go buy like the food stamp
in the welfare office absolutely it is
incredible and as i've said before a lot
of the very same people who want to make
it impossible or illegal to get an
abortion are unwilling to say well we
should expand and codify the child tax
credit at a higher level we should
provide
contraceptions comprehensive sex
education all these different things not
only are they hypocrites but they're
dangerous hypocrites
exactly all right well i thank you so
much i'll let you get to everybody else
all right jen from providence look did
you see how other than that one audio
glitch she gets right to the question
she knows other people are waiting what
what a great call really a fantastic
phone call let's go to david from
colorado david you're on the air next
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
great i wanted to talk quickly about
democratic ideals uh given that so many
supreme court justices have been
appointed by
presidents that have not won the popular
vote correct do you support the
supreme court still as an institution do
you believe it has a rightful place in
our democracy i believe it has a
rightful place in our democracy but we
need to be confident in it and we did a
story on the wednesday show about how
confidence in the supreme court has
collapsed and it's even worse than
you're pointing out so david correctly
points out
right now five of the nine justices were
chosen were nominated to the court by
presidents who lost the popular vote so
it was
roberts and alito by bush and then
gorsuch uh coney barrett and kavanaugh
by trump that's five of the nine
justices were chosen by presidents where
more people voted for their opponents
but it's even worse than that david in
addition to that
one of them quite literally should have
been barack obama's selection gorsuch
should have actually been obama's
nomination of merrick garland mitch
mcconnell got in the way of that but
then it's even worse than that not to
really depress you today david but also
the completely anti-democratic senate
where wyoming gets two senators and
california gets two senators even though
california has 30 something million
people and wyoming has not even a
million people
they
are the ones who voted to confirm these
people so it's a completely
anti-democratic process and i understand
why there's very little confidence in
the court right now but
if we could make its makeup more
legitimate as an institution i do still
think that having a supreme court is an
important thing
right right and i'm totally with you in
terms of the anti-democratic uh
uh
institutions within our system between
the electoral college and senate i'm
actually from wyoming okay i've moved
since to no offense to wyoming but
listen why do you guys have two senators
you know
yeah no it's completely uh
ridiculous yeah in my opinion but uh uh
do you have any specific reforms in mind
something that was talked about during
the 2020 campaign by a pete buda judge
was a possible makeup in which maybe
five uh justices are appointed by the
conservative uh nominee or rather
conservative presidential candidates
half or five are nominated by the
liberal uh presidential candidates and
then the remaining five are uh nominated
by the ten
seated justices do you have anything
like that in mind or any other systems i
am open to a lot of reforms one idea
that is i think similar to what you're
suggesting but not exactly it is that
you always have a 5-4 court and it's
just whoever's in power in the white
house gets the five rather than the four
that's one idea that i've seen floated
term limits is another obviously i would
love it if the president's choosing the
justices
won the popular vote and we could
actually say they actually were
reflective of the will of the people but
that requires getting rid of the
electoral college the other aspect to
this is there can't be if you're
president it
i think we have to just set a line and
even if you have a week left and you
nominate someone i think that they need
to get a confirmation hearing i don't
think you can even there it shouldn't be
an option from mitch mcconnell and
republicans to do what they did
oh i totally agree yeah um a final
question on ro uh do you think this
could be a straw that broke the camel's
back in terms of democrats winning back
a super majority and we've talked about
that i i don't know yet i i think that
this will probably inspire some turnout
for democrats in november but i don't
know about a super majority that seems
like a bit of a stretch i totally get
that i think not losing would be i think
not losing by as much would be like
probably the best they can do
yeah
we'll see what happens in november i
suppose
absolutely
david from colorado thank you so much
for the call
uh let's go next to alan from south
africa alan welcome
hey uh obligatory can you hear me i can
hear you fine
great um so my question is
what do you think
what issues do you think
joe biden can address and in what ways
to maybe save his presidency at this
point so student loan
forgiveness would be a big deal
uh see being seen as successfully
winding down russia's invasion of
ukraine not that it's his job to figure
it out but if he could credibly
negotiate an off-ramp for russia i think
that that would help him
cannabis decriminalization i think would
probably help him as well you know we
have to be realistic because we're now
under six months to these elections
and what can be done in that amount of
time i don't think there's any way in
hell that he gets immigration reform
done
i don't think he gets taxes done i don't
think he has health care so i'm just
thinking like what could realistically
happen and i think that some student
loan forgiveness could
somewhat of a solution in russia ukraine
maybe and if he was determined you know
maybe something on cannabis but i don't
i don't he doesn't seem super interested
in that
yeah uh i think i agree there um and the
other thing i wanted to ask was
would you consider covering more
international news i know you can't
cover everything it would be impossible
but there's so much going on in the
world
like for example the i don't know if you
covered this actually the
uh the election in philippines it's a
lot of things that i know your audience
is quite international yeah would you
consider um
you know covering some of some
some topics that are that are going on
in the world i mean apart from obviously
the ukrainian russian uh conflict so we
did cover the philippines election
actually it was on the bonus show you
know the award-winning world famous
bonus show that alex jones doesn't like
right uh we didn't cover it on the on
the broadcast show we uh i'm always
willing to do international stories it's
just they tend not to do well they they
get very little interest reaction
engagement or views and at a certain
point you know we're not just picking
stuff based on views but if we do
something and there just seems to be
very little interest it does make me
question whether it's the right thing to
be covering you know
right okay yeah that makes sense uh
great well thank you so much have a good
day thank you very much i appreciate it
uh let's go next to
uh oh you know what we have a caller
from the philippines caller from the
philippines welcome
good good morning david
well i have to say that the philippine
election is being chaotic and dirty
because
i voted for leni robredo and quickly
and vice president
but as the votes came in it seemed that
they voted for bongbong marcos and sarah
duterte yep and you know what they did
they brainwashed them they are the call
they're similar to the republicans in
the united states they are nothing but a
cult
so my question to you is
was the return of marcos
affect the relationship between the
united states and the philippines
because in the 1980s it has been rocky
until cory aquino came in and became
president of the philippines
and now with the return of marcos
we are on another six years of
the same old politics of
dirty tricks political dynasties and
of course vote buying do you stick do
you think it would embolden the
republicans
in 2022
i don't know the answer to that but you
have you by the way i love the energy
you're shot out of a cannon today and i
love every second of it and i would be
too if i saw that the son of a former
authoritarian now was going to be the
president of my country so i sympathize
with you completely
in terms of the biden administration
listen i don't want the biden
administration being cozy with what in
all likelihood is going to be another
authoritarian philippines regime so
that's that in terms of republicans you
know i actually am not sure
the republican
uh
i don't know what to call it love for
some authoritarians like putin for yes
for trump and putin
i don't know that it will translate to
the philippines in the same way
specifically because i don't think a lot
of republicans have any idea what's
happening in the philippines
i think i think the bbm sarah supporters
are a cult similar to the mega cult
which they will try to turn the united
states into like us
authoritarian
law democracies that
that will destroy the reputation of the
world and now we are completely laughing
stuck
and i think
marcus and duterte are completely unfit
for the roles as president and
absolutely president of the philippines
do you what do you plan to do what do
you plan to do there
now there will be some uncertainty but
one thing is for sure david yes if lenny
hobarto wins again in 2028 make make no
mistake
2022 to 2028 philippines will be dark
and bloody because this year will
celebrate the 50th anniversary of
martial law and the return of of a
marcos duterte to power would make the
philippines suffer even more similar to
what trump and
pence did in the united states from 2017
until 2021
wow
well listen you've said it all i wish
you the best and i appreciate the call
well thank you very much david and i
hope and i hope we will meet us again
real soon absolutely what a powerful
phone call there from the philippines
where things are getting very very very
crazy and we did cover that on the bonus
show
earlier this week
uh complicated circumstances that's for
sure
why don't we go next to nico from new
hampshire nico
welcome hi david how are you i'm doing
well
so um
i'm a phd student in clinical psychology
and naturally i care a great deal about
empathy
um with the midterm elections on the
horizon my question for you is why do
you think modern politicians refuse to
empathize with each other
why do they refuse to empathize you know
i don't know if refuse is necessarily
the right word i mean i think they don't
empathize with each other but for for
some of these people they seem unable to
imagine what it would be like to be in
the position of someone else it's it
seems like they they're just unable to
do it so i don't know if refuse is the
right word
yeah perhaps in the public setting in
the public eye as opposed to outside
well i do think that in that sense
there's probably some belief maybe it's
it's accurate even that if you empathize
with the other side that you're seeding
ground to them rhetorically so that then
all of a sudden you end up backed into a
corner i don't know i mean i'm thinking
out loud i can understand how they might
think that
okay yeah i was kind of having a similar
mindset about a kind of a fear of
looking weak or conceding so i i agree
with that another question is
why do you think seemingly basic amounts
of empathy that you think would be
within all people
which i'd like to think is common um
they're not reflected in our laws
can you give me an example of that
well uh we could look at the abortion
laws at this moment and that would go on
the con
a context of um
you know morality and that's a whole
other discussion but in reality of
wanting to help others
seeing that people are struggling in
certain areas and that that's not
prioritizing normal yeah i mean i think
that's the case in some of these
anti-abortion states but but that so
you're saying there are state-level
abortion laws that show no empathy
right yeah i agree with that i agree
with that i mean i think that's the way
that they're designed you've got people
writing these laws who sometimes who
have a very black white or sometimes
religiously oriented oriented view about
abortion
and they
what you and i would call empathy they
would call uh they would they might call
sin or immorality and so if that you're
not going to be you're not going to
willingly put that stuff into a law
okay well thank you for answering those
questions uh have a good rest of your
day all right and that was nico from new
haven i incorrectly said new hampshire
but that was nico from new haven let's
take a very quick break if you're
holding don't hang up because we're
going right back to the phones in a
moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show let's hear from a few
more people we do our calls via discord
you can join the discord for free at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go
uh let's go next to ben from texas ben
you're on the air
ben from texas you're on the air
and ben from texas there you are you
hear me yes i can
all right um just to the callers they're
asking uh what joe biden can do um if we
don't win the midterms for abortion
i was thinking along the lines can joe
biden do something to the effect of
withholding federal aid to states that
limit abortions past the three months or
before three months
you know that's a that's a great
question it's an empirical question that
i just don't have the answer to in front
of me uh could he withhold federal
you're just saying like stop all federal
aid to states that ban abortion before
three months
well not all federal aid something that
doesn't really affect the everyday lives
of people but can definitely hit the
wallets of the of the states of the
state governments like see the thing
about that is even if let's assume that
he could do it
it probably will hurt the people of the
states regardless i think that that's a
reality i don't know how you would hold
money from states and say we're going to
withhold the money but it's not going to
do anything bad to anybody well that
seems unlikely
right and then um like i'm from texas
i'm where this
six month abortion ban has already taken
place i work six months or six weeks or
six months or six a week oh six weeks
i'm sorry got it uh i'm a social worker
i've seen the effects that our
draconian
sexual education
has had on on uh people
you know
are like you know our foster care is
just in absolute shambles there's it's
overwhelmed underfunded
this is just
it's insane to me that that we're
limiting women's access to health care
right now do you think about leaving the
state of texas over what's going on
uh personally i have reasons that i
cannot but if i didn't have those
personal connections here in texas i
would definitely be looking to leave
gotcha well i mean that's the most
people have connections where they live
that's kind of the reality that's why
this whole if you don't like it just
move thing is is very absurd
yeah and then just one other thing just
uh i don't know if how much y'all talked
about it but uh myra flores um the
there's a runoff election going on down
here
um because our congressman um these uh
philemon vela is taking an early
retirement to be a uh to be a lobbyist
and
this is an area this is a district i
live in south texas um the rio grande
valley this area has been
a strong blue for about 40 years
and right now it's looking like the
republicans are going to be taking over
this this congressional district yeah
so
uh i mean if we if we can get the word
out that
this this uh candy might have floyd she
is
she makes she's she's another uh lauren
bulbert kind of deal oh boy i have not
been following that one i have not been
following that one but we will look into
it
yeah she's she's definitely a threat to
look out for
all right ben from texas thank you for
the very informative call
thanks david all right ben on a slight
delay there with us i don't know what
was the cause of that i don't know the
oranges of that let's go to henry from
spokane washington
did i follow the politics like pretty
well i'd say a little bit better than
the average american
i've never heard of jamie raskin i was
just curious like how feasible it is for
someone who doesn't have a national
appeal
um or
people don't know him nationally to
actually win the presidency and like
what
different moves that would take like how
possible is that yeah i mean if you ask
10 people they'll give you 10 different
opinions lots of people don't have a
national presence
until they do and sometimes running for
president is what what causes that i
mean sarah palin was virtually unknown
and by virtue of being selected by john
mccain she became a household name so
for me
jamie as i've said before i like jamie
raskin is one possibility of someone i
would like if joe biden doesn't run for
re-election
one of the things about him that i think
would be a problem is a lot of people
won't vote for a jewish guy i think that
the name recognition he can overcome by
becoming more well-known and that could
happen
but i think that he might be too
progressive for some voters i think the
judaism will be a problem for some
people so i the name recognition i'm not
worried about to be honest
okay
thank you
my pleasure there's henry from spokane
with a very pithy and concise question
which i'm glad i was able to answer
let's go to tavish from india tavish
welcome what part of india are you from
i'm from town called pondicherry
which region is that it
it's in southern india it was colonized
by the french oh you should look into it
actually i should that sounds
interesting is is the cuisine more
french
uh nothing particular like that but
there are french cafes and stuff no um
what you might find interesting is that
there was like a tintin story that was
based over here as well a tin tin store
that's interesting
yeah all right well what's on your mind
today
um i want to ask you what your thoughts
are on immigration like because a lot of
right-wingers accuse the left of being
open borders and
like just free-flowing immigration so do
you think that like there should be some
limit on immigration or do you think
that it should be an easy process
or what exactly oh yeah i mean listen my
position on this is not unique to the
united states countries have every right
and responsibility
to
set immigration policy
you they have every right and
responsibility to enforce the fact that
they have borders and to establish what
is the path to citizenship and how many
years or what what would be
disqualifying factors all of absolutely
of course uh that that should happen
what i where i think the problems are
include
what right-wingers want to do in terms
of using immigration to as some of them
want to do it allow in only white people
or mostly white people to have these
xenophobic and racist quota systems to
use immigration as a political tool
in order to try to shape the electorate
in a way that you believe is
advantageous to you uh the idea of
deporting um
individuals who were brought here as
kids by undocumented parents
uh through no fault of their own that
that's completely immoral and wrong to
do so they should get a path to
citizenship but of course yeah countries
can have immigration policy they can say
here's the amount of immigration that we
can have
and uh
of course i i
i am i have not actually even met anyone
who is like actually an open borders
person
yeah because like there are a few
leftists i've seen who are they want to
restrict immigration because they
believe that um you know it depresses
wages and things like that so i do
believe there is some truth to why they
want to restrict immigration
but i see that like there is a bit of
xenophobia which is that they want to
preserve america as an anglo-saxon white
nation is there any truth to that
is there any truth to which part
uh to like actually both like the that
the left doesn't want immigration
because of economic reasons and the
right is wanted because of cultural
reasons there's true there of course
there is truth to both of those things
you know on the wages the truth is
that the degree to which immigration
influences wages
is uh very very modest this has been
studied extensively and we have a
long-form piece about it on our youtube
channel and i also have there's a couple
of books on my reading list if you go to
davidpakman.com
economics i have a list of economics
books that i recommend and several of
them deal with this issue of immigration
and wages it has almost no impact and
much more of an impact is from
corporations that are willing to
illegally hire undocumented workers that
depresses wages much more than actual
legal immigrants coming in
right right
okay thank you for taking the question
my pleasure there's tavish from india
i'm gonna have to research that french
part of india that's very very
interesting
why don't we speak next to
oh i don't know why don't we go to our
friend bitdefender from cancun
bitdefender welcome
hello
hello
yes
hey dude i was listening to
an episode of yours earlier this week uh
with mr coleman hughes
um
and you made you mentioned this idea in
which people have to play dirty to move
forward you know how um
in certain circumstances we have to bend
or break the rules yeah i did
to be clear
what i what i said was
there are people who argue that to
achieve real change you have to play
dirty and break rules i wasn't
necessarily asserting at myself on any
particular issue but i was proposing it
as a thought element for the
conversation
yes yes exactly and i know you don't
necessarily espouse that idea okay um
and i wanted to expand a little bit on
on why you wouldn't want to expose that
because i don't think you mentioned it
in depth in that segment um but
ultimately all boils down to it is
precisely this attitude which allows
you know well well we may say well we're
doing some menial
evil for a greater good
um the same logic gets perverted to
you know defend
a greater good for myself
in exchange for a
greater hurt for the rest of the world i
guess you know let me see if i
understand what you're saying let me see
if i can summarize what you're saying
you're saying the problem with
justifying breaking rules or laws in
order to achieve a particular outcome if
you evaluate that the outcome is
worthwhile
is that once you open that door next
thing you know you're saying well maybe
murder is okay to justify a good outcome
or maybe
raping and pillaging of an entire
village or whatever you're saying that
it's a slippery slope of sorts once we
say well you can decide whether these
are laws that should be broken to
achieve a goal
you've kind of entered an area that
lends itself to all sorts of different
justifications
yes that's exactly right and the the
problem is
precisely more than the slippery slope
argument uh it's it's more of a well
they are willing to play the long game
and take tiny steps to achieve those
goals while we are usually
you know we have a mind of
we need to make big changes for the
world to be a better place
that's an interesting idea yeah i mean
the problem is that there really are
sometimes laws that are unjust and i'm
not talking about murder right but there
are sometimes laws that are unjust when
it comes to protesting or uh being heard
in different ways that that sort of that
type of thing
um so i think that that's that's the
difficulty of it bitdefender i have to
ask where are you calling from because
not only are you echoey there was like a
speakerphone announcement a couple
minutes ago
i i'm so sorry it's uh just part of the
job in a police station you know oh
you're in a position station wow wow
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry i'll have to
visit next time next time i'm in cancun
i'll have to visit the police station
and see what you're up to
the tourism police station particularly
tourism you're free to come anytime
beautiful all right bitdefender thank
you for the call
thank you david all right there's
bitdefender from mexico always great to
hear from him let's go next to alex from
baltimore alex go
hey can you hear me i can although it's
something's up with the connection but
let's see if we can struggle through it
okay how about now is that better that's
dramatically better
okay i just turned okay and i also want
to mention that i am in a quiet room
inside so we shouldn't have any loud
annoyances outside have you treated the
walls with acoustic foam
um i don't know if they did or not okay
i might have anywhere okay so i want to
get you to analyze my take on medicare
for all on a state level with the
stories coming out of california
i get i also i live in maryland the last
governor's race the democrat was very
progressive ran on medicare for a single
payer in the state of maryland okay and
i was a little hesitant on it because
on the state level the funding mechanism
is
a a better question to ask because you
know they can't just print money and
balanced budgets actually matter yep and
maryland is such a small geographical
state like i think you can be outside
this state within 30 miles no matter
where you live and i think it's more of
a reasonable argument to say all the
all the people with means that you're
going to try to get funding for can just
move to pennsylvania virginia delaware
um so i was a little hesitant to go with
it on the state level is that a decent
take do you think or am i missing
something i'm not sure i understand what
you're saying you're saying is it a
problem for state level medicare for all
that people can move into the state from
elsewhere
people know that um
because you have to raise funds for
state yeah um for medicare for all yeah
and a lot of people aren't a lot of
people
aren't going to be happy with having
higher taxes even if it's cheaper in the
long run okay and and in maryland you
could
move across the border to pennsylvania
and not have to pay those taxes so you
would lose a funding mechanism
well but if you require people to be
residents to have the the to participate
in the program then don't you solve that
issue
i suppose but my i guess my thought was
if you have uh less if you have a
an influx of people moving out to avoid
it then it's harder to raise funds for
it yeah but i think that that problem i
don't think that's really a big thing
because if a state sets up state
medicare for all they say okay here's
the way it works
in order to be to to have this
single-payer system cover you you've got
to be a resident that's it you've got to
be a resident so if people from another
state that doesn't have the system come
in they can still be seen at hospitals
but they have to bring insurance that
they have just like they do now do you
see what i'm saying
yeah i guess i see what you're saying so
you can solve that that's a solvable
problem
all right fair enough and um i know
you're at the end
quick question what is your
favorite adult beverage
my favorite adult beverage
uh i don't know i'm partial to sort of
like uh wheat and white beers
uh craft beer guy yeah yeah well you
should definitely if you're ever in
baltimore we have lots of good craft
beers you can you could check out not
ipas i hope right
they run the game and there are a bunch
of ipas but there's lots of other stuff
too i don't want any ipas anywhere near
me that's my only thing i i actually
agree with you there are some that i
think are okay but no i'm more of a
blogger i actually like dark beers now
more than i used to but anyways all
right thanks for taking my call all
right thank you for the call and what a
beautiful note on which we can end today
i'm always
devastated that i can't get to everyone
who calls in
but we will take calls again and i hope
to hear from you next time we'll take a
quick break and be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
let's go to this week's mailbag always
glad to get emails and messages from
people mostly glad anyway not i guess i
can't say always but generally speaking
you can email info at davidpakman.com if
you have something to say keep it polite
keep it quick keep it substantive and
many things this week
meeting those uh requirements not all
let's start with a couple of wackier
message no bs wrote in and said without
any evidence i should add you were paid
by the demon rats to spread
disinformation and lies with no shame no
wonder you come from one of the most
corrupt countries in the world that's a
reference to argentina argentina is very
corrupt that's true
you lied and lied since 2016 it started
with trump russia when it was proven
recently it was all a hoax that's not
true you didn't even admit it satan is
all over you but judgment day will come
i don't care about your religious
nonsense
but um prove i'm paid by the democrats
that's most of this is not the most of
these are not even empirical statements
we can't even i mean you know
satan will one day unleash uh judgment
day upon me neither one of us will ever
know that
um but
there's a specific claim that i'm paid
by the demo rats let's assume they mean
the democrats
prove it
prove it i would encoura you know every
day david you're paid by the democrats
david you're paid by george soros
shoros you guys know about that right um
prove it is my request to you thank you
very much jason wrote in and said your
show sucks ass
the little remarks you make during a
trump rally are idiotic you chime in on
the tiniest things trump says but the
big facts you completely ignore
shut up and listen and don't interrupt
perhaps you just shouldn't cover his
rallies
you're a tiny little man that hides
behind a microphone you should try maybe
play by play for the nhl maybe oh i
would love to do that thank you now that
it's a completely unhinged message at
first i don't know if you're making fun
of me for a stutter i don't have or i
know lots of people on the right have
been making fun of joe biden for having
a stutter i don't know anything about
the stutter part
but i would be totally up for doing some
sports play-by-play i think it would be
an incredible
uh thing to learn and jason listen if
you can help get me in i would love to
do that on the weekends
brett wrote in about tulsi gabbard and
says tulsi maintains that the leaker was
trying to interfere with the normal
supreme court process
isn't that the same as what the peaceful
protesters were trying to do on january
6
right well no because they you have to
remember brett
the january 6 protesters just wanted to
make sure there was no fraud
um
and okay they wanted to prevent the
election from being certified but that
would have been wrong then or something
and then the supreme court leaker
was doing something wrong even though no
crime was committed there but 700 people
have been accused of crimes related to
the trump rights don't worry about any
of that brett just listen to tulsi
she'll always tell you the truth i'm
sure
i got a message about my interest rate
segment
which said pete wrote in and said you
said to let you know if the interest
rate hike segment was useful and i just
wanted to say it was very useful cnn and
msnbc haven't explained it that
straightforward please keep educating us
you're good at explaining things thank
you pete well i really appreciate that
and like i said
those segments
almost no one watches them
but i enjoy doing them and the people
that do watch them
seem to get a lot out of them so we'll
we'll keep doing it i have no problem
with that whatsoever
let's go to our next email this one is
from john about strengthening the dollar
john says david sir i had a quick
question about strengthen the dollar i'm
a union member and recently had a
conversation with an older woman that's
also a union member and she mentioned
the phrase strengthen the dollar which i
honestly am not 100 sure what that means
but i told her so if you work the next
six months straight with our wages
how does that affect you personally and
she had that deer in the headlights look
on her face literally her eyebrows went
up quite funny because she looked so
shocked then didn't have an answer
literally said she didn't know
funny thing is i don't really know the
significance of that either i've just
learned to ask why
i also have a friend in his mid-40s
during a conversation he said something
about biden weakening the dollar
now this friend is on disability and
doesn't work so i asked him why does
that matter to you
no offense but you're on disability and
i'm pretty sure you'll be fine
yes uh that that is generally true
um and i don't honestly know about that
either but i also don't think it would
but he said the same thing a pause
and then i don't know
um
so okay here's the deal with the
strength of the dollar stuff
as a general principle
when people say a stronger dollar they
mean the dollar is worth more relative
to other currencies so there's a crazy
situation right now where the dollar
nominally is now worth more
uh or right it's almost equivalent to
the euro the value of the dollar has
increased significantly over the last
year and a half relative to the euro so
number one is a lot of people who talk
about strengthening the dollar don't
even really know how it would help them
the way it would help is it would make
imports relatively less expensive all
else being equal
okay the funniest part is a lot of the
people saying strength in the dollar
don't know that the dollar is much
stronger now than it has been in a while
and i'm not even saying biden gets the
credit for that i'm just saying it is
and many people extraordinarily confused
so john you did a great thing which is
you asked specific questions how would
that affect you
and they don't know
that doesn't mean it wouldn't affect
them they just have no idea why which is
basically just as funny
douglas wrote in about refuting election
conspiracy theorists and said many
republican candidates you interview
assert that the election was stolen
none are ever specific on how such a
conspiracy could have been carried out
in multiple states
one who directed the conspiracy
two how many people were involved and at
what levels
three why have there been no
whistleblowers well they would say that
there have been they would say the
affidavits are whistleblowers instead
they gish gallop and regurgitate mike
pillow's talking points about how many
votes were stolen in what states
can you please hold their feet to the
fire about the specifics of the
conspiracy itself i'm going to try to do
a better job on that these are all good
questions
they will
what you have to remember is it's really
common to come across something like
this and think this is bulletproof when
they start spouting you just say who
directed it
how many people were involved
and why have there been no
whistleblowers and they will tell you
with a straight face
we don't even know the full scope of who
directed it but it was democrats as well
as antifa you know whatever they'll have
an answer
and when you say how many people were
involved they'll say
it could be thousands of people and then
you'll say well why have there been no
whistleblowers and they'll say there
have been look at all of the affidavits
that were brought forward and then you
have to say well but affidavits aren't
evidence in a strict sense and that
you're in the weeds so never
underestimate their ability to put you
in the weeds no matter what sort of
refutation you offer coop wrote in
and said hey david sorry buddy
but the facial hair isn't a good look
for you my opinion only so take it for
what it's worth i will coop thank you
i'm gonna take it for nothing
that's how much it's worth to me
uh
i i just this is not a big deal guys
climate change invasion of ukraine
roe v wade overturned
weaponized trumpism my facial hair is
very very low
on the list of priorities but coop does
say keep up the good work
which i appreciate
i appreciate that thank you
dan wrote in and said
cultural marxists i i love this with the
question mark it's great david greatly
appreciate your work and was wondering
if i could get your thoughts on the
cultural marxists phrase that gets
thrown around by the right even a
british conservative politician used it
recently it seems interchangeable with
postmodernism woke mob political
correctness critical race theory and is
it possibly means little but it's just a
scary term the right uses to reference
something bad i'd be interested in your
help many thanks dan yes so cultural
marxism is another
right-wing conspiracy theory it has a
bit of an anti-semitic twist the idea is
that cultural marxism is a philosophy or
world view
that will wreck and destroy american
culture and american morality as
right-wingers see it
cultural marxism can be thought of as a
sort of political correctness on
steroids it's an assault on the american
way of life now
in its original form the idea here is
that there's a group of jewish
philosophers who fled germany in the
1930s
went to teach at columbia university and
came up with this form of marxism that
is focused on american culture it's you
might think well marxism is an economic
philosophy or a political philosophy no
the idea is these jewish individuals who
fled germany in the world war ii era
came to the u.s and said we are going to
use marxism on
american culture
and um
that's the kind of
anti-semitic element which oftentimes
the people talking about cultural
marxism are also very suspicious and
concerned about the role of jews in
american culture
and um
it's
what what it means today to people who
even know what they mean by it and some
of them don't
they mean that
uh jewish marxists or left-wing marxists
are going to invade american culture
by taking over
media systems
education
schools universities etc
and
do bad things and it's all going to be
terrible it's more or less the the gist
of it so that's cultural marxism you can
essentially i mean listen
i'm not saying ignore everything anyone
says when they use the phrase cultural
marxism but when someone says cultural
marxism unironically it should
definitely be a red flag for you that
you should really carefully scrutinize
everything that this person is saying
send in your emails if you'd like to be
featured next week info
davidpakman.com
monday may 30th we'll be doing a one-day
membership special to commemorate
memorial day
you can get on our newsletter at
davidpakman.com
and then monday memorial day you'll get
an email telling you how to take
advantage
of this great membership special we will
see you on the bonus rate today